man reibt sich wirklich nur noch die
augen meine damen und herren
mitten in der vielleicht schwersten
phase der pandemie gönnt sich die union
einen brutalen machtkampf um die
kanzlerkandidatur auf offener bühne
wahnsinn cdu und csu am rande der
spaltung das ist natürlich großartige tv
unterhaltung oder selbstversenkung der
union als serie
das könnte ich so wegwischen da ist da
ist wirklich für jeden was dabei
mobbing gewalt noch mehr mobbing fsk18
aber perfekt inszeniert allein der
auftritt der beiden rivalen vor der
showdown fraktionssitzung am dienstag
habe das gesehen mit diesem gänsehaut
soundtrack
[Musik]
wir mit den tränen kämpft er seiner
kleinen maske cdu kollegen haben ihm da
ins gesicht gesagt armin wir wollen dich
nicht bei diesem fraktions massaker zum
zeitpunkt unserer aufzeichnung sage ich
ganz ehrlich weiß ich nicht ob
inzwischen eine aufgegeben hat ob sie zu
hause vielleicht schon wissen wie der
splatter film ausgeht fest steht für
mich markus söder kennt gar keine
skrupel mehr aber gar keine präsidium
und vorstand der cdu sagen wir wollen
laschet worauf er sagt ja ich aber nicht
ich will mich von wegen die csu beugt
sich dem votum der großen schwester es
geht um die bevölkerung und die
bevölkerung liebt markus söder
also sagt markus söder und zwar ziemlich
oft weil ich unglaublich viele anfragen
aus der bevölkerung habe ich hab so
viele mails und anfragen wünsche aus der
bevölkerung bekommen ich habe aber nach
vielen wünschen auch aus der bevölkerung
als partei nach unzähligen anfragen
wünschen aus der bevölkerung auch viele
aus ihren reihen nicht nur aus bayern
sondern dass ganz deutschland
unglaublich viele menschen ich bin im
zweifelsfall auch bereit eine solche
kandidatur anzunehmen markus söder ist
so geil wenn du versuchst den byd inder
wegzuwischen explodiert das handy was
erwartet er denn soll sich die große cdu
mit ihren vielen landesverbänden jetzt
ernsthaft einer regionalen
splitterpartei aus dem alpenraum beugen
soll die cdu ihren gerade erst gewählten
vorsitzenden laschet opfern um gott
kaiser marcus milde zu stimmen
ja genau das erwartet der weil die
bevölkerung ist will und die
bundestagsabgeordneten den sünder
wirklich sehr subtil droht wenn ihr mit
armin antretet werdet ihr alle
arbeitslos wissen sie wenn 23 prozent in
der gesamt wahl weniger werden dann
können sich die konstellationen des
regierens ändern aber 23 prozent können
für viele abgeordnete union bedeuten
dass sie nicht mehr im deutschen
bundestag sind
hallo oder schöne mandate hatte hier wär
doch schade wenn die bald alle weg sind
hat ja auch funktioniert der quatsch
nicht wenige cdu leute inklusive zwei
ministerpräsidenten kollegen von laschet
haben sich inzwischen für söder
ausgesprochen
reiner haseloff sachsen anhalt im
spiegel zitat es geht nicht um
persönliche sympathie vertrauen oder
charaktereigenschaften nein leider geht
es jetzt nur um die harte macht frage
mit wem haben wir die besten chancen
verstehe sie das heißt übersetzt söder
hat zwar furchtbar an charakter und ich
vertraue ihm nudeln aber wir müssten ihn
nehmen weil wir sonst nicht gewinnen
hätte ich eine ganz tolle botschaft ja
aber genau das passiert wenn eine partei
seit jahren keine inhalte mehr hat hier
neuer wahlspot
cdu hauptsache gewinnen wie ist doch
scheißegal
sie sahen einen ball spot der christlich
darwinistischen millionen verlieren ist
was für user mich überzeugt muss ich
sagen meine natürlich natürlich sind
herrn lasches umfragewerte suboptimal
aber sie werden sicher nicht besser
durch das würdelose theater der letzten
tage
was machen die da fakt ist beim thema
wen halten sie für kanzlertauglich
landet laschet hinter olaf scholz was
physikalisch gar nicht geht und hinter
leuten die gar nicht antreten
ja und friedrich merz ein mann der
eigentlich im moment überhaupt keine
rolle mehr spielt der liegt sogar vor
armin laschet armin laschet kommt nur
auf drei prozent zustimmung
3 prozent ich meine damit liegt er noch
deutlich vor kardinal woelki prinz
marcus von anhalt und einem
eingewachsenen zehnagel ja die marke
laschet ist auch dank söder so
ramponiert derartig ramponiert man
überlegt schon in umzubenennen in armin
seneca dabei regiert der mann in seinem
bundesland nrw geräuschlos und das mit
nur einer stimme mehrheit
er ist also teamfähig ein wort das
markus söder gar nicht kennt kommt nicht
vor in seinem wortschatz und falls ich
meine persönliche meinung interessiert
wer darf mit seinem ego trip bitte nicht
durchkommen möglich aus prinzip
ich meine jetzt verkauft er sich als
merkels geistige erbe dann hat er doch
jahrelang ihre politik bis aufs blut
bekämpft
natürlich stellt sich da auch die
charakterfrage hier sehr interessant so
dass biografen plaudert nach unzähligen
treffen mit ihm aus dem nähkästchen
wie würden sie im markus bilder
beschreiben in 123 setzen da als klassen
streber der sich am meisten über die
eins im zeugnis freuen wenn die anderen
nur dreien haben also sympathisch ist
markus söder in der tat selten ja also
er ist auch nicht der typ mit dem man
irgendwie gerne in urlaub fahren würde
hui da weiß ich aber wer nächste
weihnachten kein geschenk vom sünder
kriegt ja ich meine selbst sodass corona
bilanz
ist übrigens nicht ansatzweise so doll
wie er immer behauptet
googeln sie zum beispiel noch mal aus
spaß das test debakel an bayerischen
autobahnen letzten sommer nur ein
beispiel
ja das muss man ihm lassen ein
blendender verkäufer seiner selbst und
vielleicht schafft es damit sogar
irgendwann ins kanzleramt
denn der job da in berlin der war ja
schon immer ein absoluter traum
ich fahre gern nach berlin aber wissen
sie was das schönste in berlin ist der
weg zurück nach bayern
das ist mit abstand das schönste an
berlin das ist wie ein befreiendes
gefühl ja du dann bleib doch in bayern
ich werde schon ok in jeder weiß dass
die größte leidenschaft von markus söder
immer markus söder bleiben wird und
trotzdem diese fantastischen
umfragewerte ernsthaft was stimmt nicht
mit uns deutschen dennis knossalla ist
der heute show betriebs psychologe
knossalla muss man sich sorgen machen um
uns ich fürchte ja in krisenzeiten
bricht sich leider eine tiefsitzende
teutonische sehnsucht nach führung bahn
nach dem virilen macher der sich kümmert
dem strengen papa gehört zu den eher
unbekannten corona symptomen und befällt
sogar schon jugendliche bei tik tok zum
beispiel und ich wünschte so sehr ich
hätte mir das ausgedacht wimmelt es von
ernst gemeinten söder fan videos wie
demir
[Applaus]
[Musik]
erschütternd darunter teenager
kommentare wie menschen nahe politiker
der humor hat oder ich finde den so hot
saw ii gott für diese kinder waren ja
hilfe unbedingt ich empfehle da meist
gesprächstherapie und wenn das nicht
hilft elektroschocks im übrigen spiegeln
die jungen leute natürlich nur ihre
doofen eltern denn die leben das ja vor
die plötzliche verehrung für einen
pathologischen narzissten mit kreativen
verhältnis zur wahrheit für einen mann
der sonntag verspricht wenn die cdu mich
nicht will ziehe ich mich zurück um mode
dazu sagen ja egal ob die mich wollen
ich werde in jedem fall kanzler für
soviel er braucht eine zweite hose weil
man natürlich jetzt in berlin so ein
bisschen als wortbrüchig naja nehmen
könnte komm mir nicht
super auch der blick zum journalisten
hast du ein problem mit mir vor die tür
lehrbuch hier sehen wir wirklich alle
kernbausteine des narzissten 0 empathie
mir doch egal ob die union zerbröselt
nur so erklären sich solche subtile bus
halten wenn man hört dass in der
fraktion ist wohl großen
diskussionsbedarf gibt dann denke ich
ist es klug dass man nicht nur in einem
kleinen im hinterzimmer entscheidet
großartig präsidium und vorstand der cdu
machte er mal eben zum hinterzimmer
ständig weil die sind es tablets sind
und er ist der mann des volkes
genial wir erleben hier gerade live die
neueste verpuppung eines mannes der sich
ständig neu erfindet zählen sie mal
zusammen egomanie penetrante angeberei
mit umfragewerten wortbruch auf die
eigene partei pfeifen twenty four seven
aktiv bei social media verbreitet unter
mitarbeitern ein klima der angst
an wen erinnert uns das
also herr knossalla ich mache ja jeden
quatsch mit aber der schnauze ich habe
studiert
die diagnose steht söder leidet unter
morbus trank heißt wenn er nicht kanzler
wird müssen wir damit rechnen dass er
seine fans und die vielen verstrahlten
kinder bei tik tok dazu aufrufen wird
den reichstag zu stürmen wie in
washington und am ende steht die scheuer
mit büffel hörnern auf der empore und
schreibt markus ich will ein kind von
dir
ich freue mich darauf denn das knossalla
so aufnahme hallo
dies ist die automatische and cut von
oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich